und bekamen zu eurem allerliebsten blick
format
doch die man aber moment mal
mal war es sind auch heute nur zwei da
und ich weiß wirklich nicht was passiert
aber ich frage ist einfach mal gefehlt
denn da noch mal richtig begrüßen
also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob
das wirklich kennt ein großer kessel
wir sind wieder alle drei lieblings 3
koch dezibel das kurz eine sache gibt es
immer noch schön dass selbst mit ihrer
geschlechtsumwandlung immer näher rückt
immer noch im hintergrund stehen wenn
wir so machen ich will es einfach gut
das ist das dritte rad vorbei
das kennt ihr einfach reifer sich so
verändern kann aber ich immer noch
ich finde hier drin ist es viel zu warm
ich mache mein hemd auf weil es so warm
hier drin
ich finde das viel zu kühl war es super
wir haben hier heute ist das thema weil
wir so eine lustige bgh die machen zwar
spaß
cocktails oder 3d die cocktail wird
und es geht ihr darum das so im studio
am kiosk gibt so viel zu den fünf
kreativer sein und jetzt stellen wir die
zutaten vor ich bin dazu da anfangen
damit er einfach
[Applaus]
was für ihn oder nicht was behält sich
apple ihn kam war es vor 15 oder 16
jahre war habe ich meine freunde
kennenlernen
jetzt aber nicht nur einfach nur
hingehen und einkaufen sondern kommt
also dass in spanien gilt die ich
erkennen september gearbeitet und ich
bin mal ratsam feierabend mich da
reingegangen und habe gesagt ein aber
geht man dann haben wir immer ein
bisschen und da haben wir spezielle
sachen einfach im bett um die einfach
sehr speziellen sie einfach sehr typisch
sind
berlin ist meine zweite typische zutat
aus einem berliner spezies stern eine
dritte typische zutat weniger luft das
ja ein cockpit ist haben wir auch schon
besorgt der war so leer
der war schon her wir haben hier so
gekauft und so habe ich kopf der kirchen
gekauft ich habe wohl war ein kopftor
von vreni wohnen frucht ja ja ja ja
meine eigene idee multivitamin könnte
noch zu wenig wieder und das einführen
dazu da eine ganz klassisch neufeld
dann habe ich ganz klar
an bord geholt den ich nicht kenne 150
kostet ja dann habe ich das sie geholt
einfach was auf die finger schauen
das finde ich keine ahnung das wird auch
zu mir wie nichts anderes ist immer ein
stückchen sechs meilen ca jetzt an
dieser stelle sagen vor ja du hast jetzt
aber auch schon wieder so scheint also
meine zutaten sind natürlich eine
klassische club man nicht eine idee ist
es auch war ja also meine nächste zutat
ist auch classic nein ich kenne ich also
meine nächste zutat kenne ich liebe dich
bei den zutaten kann ich nicht wirklich
auch katholische st ich bin du kenne ich
also meine nächste zutat ist immer bei
mir das nicht voran
ich habe für sich als auch seltsam
tetrapacks dann weiß natürlich keine
obst und kein grund also kein frisches
brot gibt habe ich
für die truppen dort getauft und noch
klassischer stick software dann zum
immer so und nun link wir los
[Musik]
mögen die das spiele ich mag es immer
noch mal rausnehmen
mit kelly ist viel besser was macht denn
diese andere da ist ja langsam also das
ding das ich bin halb fertig das heutige
soft matter euro belassen
so leide
musiker ja wirklich einfach was ist denn
los ist
das ganze soll sich ein stift wie geht
das denn du musst den sicherheitschef
daraus ziehen
[Musik]
was mich schlagen allein als wenn man
sagt jetzt natürlich blöd dass wir beide
jetzt schon fertig so nicht auf den
tisch
[Musik]
na klar ich bin will ich schlafen möchte
sich ganz bewusst in dieser sekunde
die bringen das ist das zeug haben also
dass ich jetzt sagen die eltern der
großen effekt nämlich gar nicht es macht
wirklich dann sieht es auch nicht ein zu
klein
was darf der duma darauf macht grund das
ding herum ist glauben es wäre einfach
ein schock gerade zu überbrücken mit den
physiker will ist das einfach nur so
erst mal keinen alkohol dann irgendwo
findet heute ist komplett
ich war letztes also dass hier dieser
cocktail gleich noch mal präsentiert
einfach meine jugend und was ich so
getan habe in meinen mitte bis ende 20
die kirche steht für eine freundin die
grundlage auf der wir aufgebaut haben
dann weiterhin mit einem stern dazu kam
geschmacks geben und dazu natürlich
natürlich noch der noch der kleine
hinter also über ihn läuft
damit das ganze auch ein bisschen
sessions reinbringt in dem ich mal gut
und es schmeckt ein bisschen nach fuß
das eis macht jetzt gerade ganz still
ist müssen nach fuß wenn der gleiche
mensch
es ist wirklich also ich hab ich hab'
ich habe viel gelernt in meiner zeit und
das ist häufig das learning ist süß
immer besser deswegen habe ich mir hoch
zu garten einfach nur ein bisschen
anders
um das ganze so ein bisschen anzutreiben
die platt gedrückt und auf jeden fall
schöne zutaten also irgendwie kennt ihr
noch nicht glaube und ich glaube das ist
auch ganz gut geworden ich habe noch
hier an der seite muss man fairerweise
zu sein die ananas ein bisschen
interviews mit mitbürger
gianni gianni meetings mit sugar ist das
ist natürlich schwierig wenn man so ein
großes stück besteht in den sturmreihen
aber es gibt ja durch den energie
windkraft strafe reduziert
richtig und das ist eigentlich
kompletten kann man so wechselt der
krise gemacht
[Musik]
das ist nicht das also ich kann es ja
nur anbieten einfach mal so einfach
super infos zu essen da waren
zucker eingelegt war zum spielen wenn
ich natürlich laufen will
in solchen eis essen
doch kann auch ein bisschen ein bisschen
geschwollen und ich kann also dass auch
ein iphone software durch immer alles
verkauft
wenn wir mal drei cocktails die beiden
das ja so eine sache mit dem essen heißt
das gut ist jetzt mein freund hat dann
hat man ja immer eigentlich da ich meine
schon irgendwie was gekauft hat sowieso
die immer optisch das sieht ganz toll
aus ganz fantastisch wirklich wunderbar
hier ist noch ein bisschen süß kam weil
man nach stadt auch die haben manchmal
gerne sich karten beim spiel und man
denkt ich probiere jetzt einfach mal
mein tweet also eigentlich muss man
dafür also nochmals ein kaugummi kauen
[Musik]
wenige kaufen die zunge mal ließen sie
gut aus ich probiere jetzt trink ich
hasse dich bin ich finde das alles war
gut
hast du das mit dem eis der schmeckt
echt gut der schmeckt ganz gut und das
finde ich nicht gut und das finde ich
nicht auch nicht gut weil du hast schon
rheinhessen zu kaufen und trotzdem
schmeckt dann kommt ihr gut und ich muss
sagen mir reicht's auch langsam der
schmäh gab magath haben wir sie so hoch
man müsste meinen sind zwar im 3
es habe also bin ich in peking offiziell
ja die hua moment leider dieses format
macht nicht so spaß wenn ich gewinne
das ist einfach toll also bleib hier die
beiden noch nicht zu sagen
die zweite mann johnny lee goldkurs mit
dem podcast geht auf dem kanal aber
diesen termin zwar wussten wenn wir
machen beständig 43 bald kommt schon das
nächste break und sie waren teils sie
kennen jetzt so minister keine sage ich
mal richtig vermissen wollten beim
nächsten mal wieder kommunizieren wie
hat sie gesagt ich will da nicht mehr
kommen
mit dabei sind die auch schon bald
wieder in der nächsten folge zwei
politessen also viel spaß weil ich
manche tiefer hier seht ihr wie du bist
weg ins camp
[Musik]
da für diese zu was ich jemals gesehen
habe ok bei